wir sind jetzt verbunden mit marco
manthey er ist direktor der motorradshow
night of the jumps hallo herr manthey
hallo
sie sind ja mit ihrer show in großen
hallen also sie spielen oder lassen die
motorräder wirklich vor tausenden von
leuten 20.000 leute fahren
wie ist die situation ist gerade bei
ihnen seit märz haben wir quasi keine
arbeit mehr wir sind abgefangen worden
wir sind informiert worden dass die
events ausfallen
außerdem hoffen wir organisieren uns
irgendwie in der hoffnung dass bald
wieder was möglich ist
das heißt ich will ist das finanziell zu
sehen sind sie da in vorkasse getreten
wann sie da auch um die zukunft ist die
kasse leer
wie ist die lage bei ihnen ja ich meine
wir gern keinerlei einkommen momentan
sponsoren in zahlen nicht ticket gelder
liegen festgelegt bei den
ticketverkäufen
da ist einfach ein moment nichts zu
holen unsere leute sind auch kurzarbeit
wir probieren so gut es geht irgendwie
im online-bereich noch den kopf
hochzuhalten den leuten zu zeigen wir
sind da wir machen weiter schlichtweg
fakt ist wir wissen nicht was glauben
sie denn ich habe sie eben auch
mitbringt besprochen dass die leute
wieder zurückfinden so
massenveranstaltungen oder sind die auf
dauer tot
nein ich glaube schon dass wir wieder
irgendwann auch an die anderen sachen
anknüpfen können
aber ich kann auch die leute verstehen
die momentan noch ein bisschen angst
haben in eine große halle zu gehen nicht
zu wissen was auf sie zukommt die sind
die ganzen sachen aber ich glaube schon
denn der mensch ist ein herdentier der
sdp unterhaltung haben mit der haltung
hat immer funktioniert und ich glaube
steht werden da auch wieder zurückfinden
wann kann ich nicht sagen aber ich
glaube das ist keine frage also
eigentlich optimistische aussichten
sehen sie es auch so
man muss das ganz klar sehen dass ich
glaube dass das langsam wie er schon
richtig sagt langsam wieder sich
steigern wird wir werden das problem
haben in der 5000 alle eben mit 22 3000
menschen oder mit der hilfe der sonne
zweieinhalb da agieren zu müssen und das
wird sich langsam wieder steigern
die frage ist eben die aufgaben wann es
weiß keiner genau jetzt höre ich ja
gestern wunderbare nachrichten dass
demnächst einen impfstoff die chance
wird immer größer das sind so weltweit
so viel unternehmen am probieren und
machen und tun dass wir da eine chance
haben irgendetwas zu finden dass man
will ich dir sagen kann okay wir können
wir die menschen zusammenführen und das
ist natürlich werde der schlüssel zur
lockerheit wieder zum normalen und das
ist die frage ich hoffe dass indianer
was passiert man muss das ja schon ein
bisschen abhaken in gewisser weise nur
kleinen verein schon werden stattfinden
können die ganz großen werden sicherlich
nicht vor frühjahr befürchte ich 22
wieder losgehen wenn überhaupt muss ich
sagen und wir werden es finde ich über
die steigerung langsam hinbekommen aber
es wird ein bisschen dauern und ich
drücke den medizinern biologen wie sie
alle heißen sie sich auch schon geirrt
haben drücke ich die daumen dass wir
alle irgendwas haben demnächst profi
hoffnung schöpfen können und wieder
wirklich muss er gleich ein impfstoff
sein der alles deutet aber dass wir
wirklich hoffnung haben